[Musica]
once again ripari
lo sapevo ap e soci forse una roba da
allora iniziamo ciao mi chiamo lorenzo
non bevo mai c'è solo uovo che partono
cose long e caucciù rage su rudolf merz
ok due razze in ogni anno sulla terra un
giorno la guerra interruppe questa dopo
la lunga battaglia agli umani
diventarono vittoriosi è partito così
volevo fare la introduzione ai partito
loro isolare gli mostri nel sotto terra
con una magia
diversi anni dopo e io devo partire così
perché non c'è la pausa è partito subito
con the boat le leggende dicono che chi
scale alla montagna non ritornerà mai a
partenio desktop colori ritorna che un
piacere perché è successo
e successo qualcosa è tornato il mio
desktop non so perché ciao amici a
qualcuno è entrato di sotto adesso leggo
regala scusatemi è partito tutto a caso
non so che che è cascato da sotto
[Musica]
macché
questa è la intro ecco questo era adesso
posso fare la intro io me stai fermo lì
bello a tutti i ragazzi benvenuti questo
canile sono faringei come state io
benissimo sto bene cavolo se sto bene
porca vacca mai stato meglio ragazzo
basta quante volte la intro allora
niente oggi siamo su ander tail volete
favorire non vi consiglio bene ringrazio
4 ranger grazie ragazzi grazie a tutti
ciao grazie mille all'ora in regola in
tre parti
volevo fare under the hill però non
posso farlo come video dedicato tipo
residenti vo il tipo o perché la gente
mi caga le palle che taglio tanto su
hunt su del tar 1 e mi ha creato le
balle non hanno forse capito il tipo di
video che io faccio però insomma il
fondo mi aveva strascicato i maroni per
come giocava del tar un ea me se poteva
vista quando mi dicono come giocare una
roba io li schiaccia rai tutti quindi me
lo gioco come voglio io e me lo faccio
in live punto non ho capito se c'è un
italiano non ho capito niente
se in italiano o meno perché non so se
qua si avvia non sembra in italiano
vabbè dai partiamo
io non so magari molti di voi hanno
giocato io non so niente di under the io
non so neanche come si chiama il
protagonista né me né bene me ne frego
voglio vederlo adesso non ho mai io non
so nulla nulla
non solo anche voi schiavi protagonista
lei ha solo istruzioni z lanter per
confermare xo shirt per cancellarne
[Musica]
grazie aurora un abbraccio a voi quando
i tuoi hp raggiungono lo zero per di wow
mai visto questa cosa in nome dell'umano
caduto come si chiama lo chiama come lo
chiamò ragazzi penso onofrio novabell
agli champs scegliamo il nome decente
facciamolo dai facciamolo lo lori come
mi chiamavo nei giochi di pokémon quando
ero piccolo lory ho sbagliato scrivere
il mio nome perfetto si nomi zoomare il
mio nome ti ringrazio sei molto gentile
però per averlo fatto
ciao ciao cli pat bacio ma è come andrè
come under telecom e under the il cavolo
che coincidenza
ragazzi io non so se qualcuno di voi
conoscono andate destato categorizzato
anzi dichiarato come uno dei migliori
giochi degli ultimi dieci anni fatto
sviluppato tutto da una singola persona
non mi ricordo il nome la vado a cercare
subito che ha fatto il gioco la
programmato ha fatto il design ha fatto
le musiche ha fatto anche la pasta
mentre sviluppava gioco che si chiama
gerry scotti nostra toby fox in italiano
tobia volpe bene il gioco è uno dei più
belli degli ultimi dieci anni così dice
la gente
vediamo ciò sarà verrò in toscana fa
anche rima
non è vero ciao navi ma choc ciao amici
io sono questo o dei capelli lunghi sono
caduto su dei fiori del gol all in al
flop il flop in the flowers sono flop i
fiocchi fluffy fiore 6 nuovo nel
sottosuolo non lo sei
dovresti essere molto confuso già paolo
bacio
[Musica]
qualcuno dovrebbe insegnarci le cose che
funzionano qua credo che sia io a
doverlo fare ok pronto cominciamo sila è
qual è la tua anima lo vedi correlato
anima e della culminazione le tue essere
ok
la tua anima inizia a non solo devo dire
animale piccola ma può crescere e
diventare forte se fa vidi velo ok
i livelli sono stanno per l'amore certo
vuoi un po di amore vero ho certo datemi
l'amore che volete da preoccuparti né e
condividere un po con te ragazzi se
alcuni voi non ha mai giocato ad under
the questa qua il video perfetto perché
io non so niente quindi sì sì sì sì cat
menia si pensi a devo prendere a non
dovevo prenderlo che video attenti
allora capiamoci subito in questo mondo
e uccidi o sei ucciso perché qualcuno
dovrebbe bypassare un'opportunità come
questa ma stai calmo muori la tua
sorella ma scusami stop da quando sto
fiore un testa di culo ma ti ho fregato
water fa dio mio mia madre di delta rune
grazie mister shock grazie francesco
grazie gaia che ti arriva la creatura a
torturare una povera
povero innocente non essere spaventato
bimbo mio mi chiama torje che c'è che la
che il tech air undertaker delle urne
passo in questo posto ogni giorno per
vedere se qualcuno e caduto giù e io
sono cascata pesche stronzo se il primo
umano a venire qui in tanto tempo
vieni ti guiderò attraverso le catacombe
grazie storie da questa parte va bene
[Musica]
che bello questo per salvare e come
under the lab orco demonio come del tar
unione navigando che è venuto dopo del
fango
[Musica]
magari non so niente di soggiorno non
sono davvero se non avete mai giocato ad
andartene guardatelo perché dovrebbe
valerne la pena a detta di 99 per cento
dei videogiocatori nel mondo
benvenuti nella nostra nella tua nuova
casa innocente permettimi di educarti in
questa operazione delle rune
le rune sono pieni di puzzle funzioni
anti che attraverso diversa e non è in
italiano sto gioco devo tradurre tutto
attraverso diverse azioni delle chiappe
devi sociali e muoverti dalla stanza
all'altra si per favore si vede lo
faccio lo devo fare
no non devo farlo perché l'hai fatto già
tu quindi a posto
grazie johnnie to make progress per fare
progressi qua devi devi utilizzare
diversi switch non preoccuparti non ho
capito niente di quello che ci ha
scritto lì premi z si è già scritto
bellissimo premi z per leggere i
cartelli grazie senza saperlo questo non
lo avrei letto prof
geniale come ecco lo switch indicato da
tante frecce schiaccio tutti gli switch
splendido sono fiera di te piccolo che
vidi a picco
muoviti muoviamoci alla sua sia una
stanza certo come un umano che vive nel
sottosopra cioè nel sottosuolo i mostri
potrebbero attaccarti hai bisogno di
essere preparato perché situazione
comunque non preoccuparti il processo è
molto semplice quando incontrò il nemico
entrerà in una battaglia come in pokémon
quando sei in una battaglia puoi
iniziare una conversazione amichevole
[Musica]
aspettare potrebbe risolvere il
conflitto praticare la il dialogo
tutte turni non solo degli ok al
manichino ok dialogo comunichino dialogo
act parla ciao manichino se proprio un
bel manichino e non sembra avere molto a
conversazione grazie alle bolle belotta
in panne manichino storie nel sembra
felice con te sì ho avuto un dialogo
molto più interessante di quelli che
avevo con la mia ex grazie giulia per ad
hansen e un bacio broffice sa molto bene
sei veramente bravo grazie grazie
c'è un altro passo in questa stanza
voglio vedere se riesce a risolverlo non
è vero mi hai mentito che una rana ti
attacca parla la rana non posso parlare
alla rana che strano ha sì forse sì ah
sì puoi fare un complimento la rana
daranno non capisce che cosa dici cosa
quindi sa se n'è andato a proprio hai
vinto
va bene certo se parla nera ne voglio
parlare ragazzi che volete
questo è il puzzle ma prendi la mia mano
per un momento
[Musica]
non ne capisco il senso fa tutto lei
grazie
i puzzle sono molto sono un po
pericolosi per ora hai fatto un lavoro
incredibile è fatto tutto tu piccolo mio
comunque o delle una richiesta difficile
da chiederti e vorrei che cammina si
fino alla fine della stanza per conto
tuo
ok perdonami per questo per cosa che se
c'è non ho capito cosa dovrebbe
succedere se cammino per la strada della
stanza per conto mio però quanto tempo
ha forse devo tornare indietro aiuto
grazie gianni un bacio chiedeva è un
enigma ragazzi quanto ci scommettete c'è
una porta nascosta da qualche parte
sicuro può tornare indietro
eccolo scherzavano non era un apporto
c'è una colonna a ekoto vista ratings my
fire dong won ria e di no lei pil non me
ne sono andata certo lo so
ero dietro questa colonna per tutto il
tempo grazie per aver creduto in me
prego
comunque c'è un'importante ragione per
cui abbiamo fatto questo esercizio per
testare la tua indipendenza
devo fare dei lavori e devi stare da
solo per un po per favore rimani qui è
molto pericoloso esplorare per conto tuo
ho un'idea ti darò un telefono non mi
aspettavo mai di ricevere un telefono
[Musica]
non sono rune sono rovina o porca vacca
sori o lento rune è perché leggo la
veloce grazie gr erano rune kirikù un ep
i suoi criteri non so chi sia
ugo sasso
ti sembra in one capo e un bacio grazie
ray ai no runer un nel suo arrivo a
letto rovine
c'e bisogno di una grazie per
l'accoglienza non avrei continuato a
lecce rovine
c'è bisogno di un aiuto per qualcosa fai
una chiamata attenzione d'accordo ok
l'avranno di prima pronto e torje è un
attimo meritato il telefono gene
chiamato provincia un telefono il suo
gioco non hai lasciato la stanza verona
o non sono un po di puzzle che devo
ancora spiegarti vorrei dovrebbe essere
troppo pericoloso provare a risolverli
da test per conto tuo
fai bravo d'accordo d'accordo sto nella
stanza lì a fare niente
[Musica]
io devo andare sulla rana non ho capito
ripi tripit e schiude scusami umano a
parla è quella donna parla un po di
consigli per fatti batteri mostri se tu
parli un certo modo combatti finché non
gli sconfitti
magari non ti vogliono combattere più
mostro non vuole combattenti per favore
usa pietà umano che lewis moon ha per me
un po che non questo act consola
poverino
[Musica]
a metà della tua prima parola wiz moon
inizia a piangere ininterrottamente
corre via ma poverino povero cristo cosa
gli ho fatto
vabbè hai ancora che non è il
marshmallow nella boxe in no perché è
registrato un mesetto fa con l'unboxing
quindi non ce l'ho ancora c'è un
giochino non mangiava finita ma basta ai
mariti spuntano tipo in pokémon merci
spero mi ha attaccato pets sente
schifoso act comprimeva è un complimento
la rana non capisce quello che fa che
dici o non capisce ragazzi odo picchiare
questo io ci provo
l'ultima volta è treat non so cosa
voglio dire non capisce ma basta poi lo
meno lo meno perché non possono davanti
veniamo la rana ma ha fatto pure male
sotto pezzente madonna eppure resistente
che cos'era
[Musica]
dove centrare il mezzo immagini 3d
esperienze due di loro perfetta
ciao che per lotti a questo è un puzzle
immagino ok provando ciao sono storie
per nessuna ragione in particolare quale
preferisci la cannella o il batter stop
non so cosa sia però cannella grazie
molte prego che cadetto ma passa non è
che ti dispiace del butter scuse ei
google traduci butters coach
non ho capito cosa ha detto droga no
comunque non mina che milone nigro anzi
molto preferenza era
ma io non capisco perché mi sta facendo
sul discorso di pietanze
vabbè a caso no
mi sa che devo porca vacca la rana
analisi moon wish non si terrorizza
tranquillo prova terrorizzarlo si è
cagato addosso ma no ma mi attacca come
che strano semplicemente parlando li
lavo terrorizzato pensavo di consola lo
so che adesso si è cagato cioè se lo
terrorizza non si caga se vi parlo si
sono bravo a risolvere gli enigmi non
l'avreste mai detto
ma basta ciao non hai allergie vero è
perché lo chiedo
no nessuna ragione nessuna ragione dopo
tutto ragazzi non sto capendo tory al
parco schifo c'è il pavimento che si
distrugge ma ste cose qua per favore non
passare sulle foglie sa bene sembra
simpatico questo gioco quindi cosa ma
c'è una porca vacca cos'è sta roba qua
flyer flirta con sta roba qui of realtà
[Musica]
stai facendo del wii goal non so cosa è
tipo un movimento e lui lo sta facendo
uguale a me buche in crisi la
conversazione sexy juego però continua
ad attaccarmi sto pezzente
cosa devo fare una faglia di nuovo ma
continua attaccarmi che lo fa bene
l'anno lotta chiamo facciamo un'altra
roba limite it
raga la gente che io hanno ammazzati
tutti faccio prima
ciao squash
[Musica]
ma posso fare mercy tipo a ok posso fare
mercy non lo sapevo ok c'è un modo per
passare di qua asfor ci si aspetta ho
capito devo seguire il pavimento
quindi o passare tutto a destra andare
in fondo giu
poi su poi giù poi ok ci prova a
ricordarmelo
credo è e lo stesso immagino mamma mia
[Musica]
era che non mi ricordo
ok pensavo di andar giù e mercy mercy no
ho sbagliato non volevo farti al mare
scusami infatti non gli ho fatto niente
[Musica]
mercy flick
ok
all ei ragazzi nota player
[Musica]
ciao sarà
tanti gli auguri per l'operazione un
bacio ciao anche a te michele io dovrei
aggiornare la pagina della live
scusatemi che non vedo più niente
[Musica]
ok perfetto elettrico
dai che papà mercy mercy
che bello falso pressione skype e tipo e
pokémon però non ho capito facendo
escape di vista che non salvo risalgo di
livello ei partner
chi ti ha detto che puoi spostarmi mi
sta parlando la roccia
quindi mi stai chiedendo di muovermi ok
solo per te zucca che mi ha dato della
zucca sipro di muoverti di più si no
d'altra parte se risponde esattamente a
quello che dico ok penso di avercela
fatta
raga mi sa che devo spostare mia webcam
che dite no non lo so se devo spostare
la mia webcam adesso capiamo perché i
dialoghi sono o sopra o sotto vediamo
dai
[Musica]
ma dai devi stare fermo
mamma mia che stai fermo magagna guarda
è carino mi piace cavolo ciao suns
grazie alla donazione ancora non ci sei
arrivato a te è l'unico per scola il
personaggio che conosco e suns perché
c'è un graffito vicino al paesino dove
sono nato io di suns non so chi l'ha
fatto è un genio quando aveva il nome
già lo potevi risparmiarlo per fare
finale bello non devi uccidere nessuno è
ormai come fai fare tutto un gioco senza
ammazza nessuno ormai no vabbè allora
non in nome in giallo non amazzone non
l'ho ammazzata
se c'è un formaggio qua cell e formaggio
che rimasto qui per molto tempo è
attaccato al tavolo perché questa cosa
[Musica]
albenga
a questo fantasma continua a dire
fortissimo continuamente facendo finta
di dormire muoverlo con la forza se hai
a questo è giallo come lo vedo 6 giallo
da dal basso act share la serie the
dai al nup stub look un sorriso paziente
non si è cagato il sorriso questo è
difficile ragazzi parka vacca ma colpito
knapp st blocco dei miei stivali flirt a
rally not feeling up to it right now
sorry cosa treat uno sguardo crudele
niente ragazzo per le sta provando tutte
e nessuna di queste sembra dalli
fastidio a non ha senso dell'umorismo
vabbè ace che serve serve per vedere se
il mostro è stabile per dirla
normalmente petit lo spaccare perché non
mi cagli
mamma mia quanto poco da noi che li
faccio no ragazzi impossibile scriva sta
roba
madonna è assurdo schivare il suo
attacco è impossibile wi fi
[Musica]
parco schifo mi becca sempre secondo me
mi fa anche
ecco questo è facile mie l'altro è
difficilissimo
a devo insistere se insisto ma io non
sono una persona paziente quindi se
insisti il tipo
insistiamo a è vero si sta cominciando a
divertire gli ho detto no è una
barzelletta
insistiamo l'ultima volta dai napoli
mostrarti qualcosa farmi provare
[Musica]
mi piace un sacco
mercy non far emersi
[Musica]
no non dovevo fare mercy
cosa devo fare ragazzi facili ancora cer
ok se messo a piagne
lewis cosa vuol dire air one o rovine
[Musica]
allora i wings vuol dire
rovine che il pirla che mi aveva detto
che voleva dire rune porco demonio era
rovine lo so io l'inglese parka vacca
spesso vengono le rovine perché non c'è
nessuno in giro ma oggi ho incontrato
qualcuno di nice
come sono buttato fuori j
sto parlando ancora ti lascio perfetto
grazie grazie
ragazzi io non so né un finale
nell'altro perché di vita che se sette
gol se non ammazzo nessuno un finale se
li ammazzano mila tanto uno l'ho già
ammazzato quindi chi se ne frega faccio
faccio un po di tutto non so hanno un
ammazza nessuno sono di vento scemo palo
ho realizzato che è un bel po da che non
che non pulisco a non mi aspettavo di
avere compagnia così presto
[Musica]
sono probabilmente un sacco di cose
ah but here and there e poi prenderle ma
non portarle più di quanto hai bisogno
un giorno potrei vedere qualcosa che
veramente ti piace
ok click va beh
non ho capito le chiamate di tauria
chiacchie cosa servono
no un enigma vabbè dai
non ci credo era quella giusta subito
l'ocst rioni e ok proviamo a fare dongpi
con sto provando a fare quello bravo
file alison van ghezzi sussistendo è
continuo a insistere
continuerò così tutta la vita vero
ragazzi ditemi la verità può cambiare
facciamo p.col
io lo slate snipe mannaia
ecco sapevo ragazzo schiattando in tutto
questo regalo devo menare non si fa non
si fa nome non lo meno va bene perfetto
lo sto menando perché non anche facendo
più volte le stesse cose non mi pagava
ecco perché non voglio fare la pacifica
run così si chiama
[Musica]
perfetto era giusto visto riuscito a
entrare l'unica stanza che era quella
giusta in una su sei che culo ragazzi
vado a prendere un secondo la bottiglia
d'acqua arrivo che ciò sete arrivo
incoming
[Musica]
e l'ultima acqua che ho in casa e questa
l'ultima che ho
[Musica]
che due palle i file di under the hell
ora che sono un po chi chi gioca da
under taylor sempre nottata io sta roba
è un po troppo come se fosse una
religione no è un po li capisco anch'io
sono così tipo con metal gear solo che
fan di under tail chi si approccia ad
under the hill non sa una sega quindi il
se avete giocato andate li sapete
l'inglese gil è let the players lei lo
so questa roba perché anche in del
talune non potevo fare niente senza che
è uno switch premier lo si non è
successo niente la tua sorella ci sarà
un ordine
questo è successo niente porca vacca o
un repellente rega veramente che
fastidio io questi di meno perché non mi
milan troppo fastidio
[Musica]
aia porco demonio ragazzi sto veramente
morendo ma ciò che posso recuperare la
mia vita in qualche modo perché ci
schiatto io l'ho sti qua lo so già 7
esperienza c'è un modo per aprire come
si apre il menu così
no devo trovare un qualcosa per
un salvataggio qualcosa aiuto porca
vacca
se riesci a leggerlo premi lo switch blu
e dove col demonio stico basta basta che
fastidio quanta gente
[Musica]
ok 1 andato c'è
vabbè non ci credo è rimasto solo lui
mister mi sta spaccando lui solo aiuto
no
ragazze qualcuno mi tocca sono morto
però vabbè
lo switch blu sta qua
se non l'ho letto lo schiacciato lo
schiacciato se riesci a leggere questo
premi lo switch bruno schiacciato non va
male che c'è un nascosto a vedi era
dietro porco schifo non ti prego niente
mostra niente non sentiamo studenti
mostra insieme al free mortacci the dude
ma che palle a sono scappato poi
scappare perfetto se riesce a reggere
questo premi lo switch rosso
[Musica]
ok
dai che fastidio basta vegeto e di sono
scappato vai male perché sono muoio mi
secca no qua ce n'è solo uno solo giallo
the green switch e sarà questo dai no no
dai ti prego che odio profondo ragazzi
davvero
mi ha veramente fregato
e dov'è che ne so sarà qua
ma ganna
porterei per un brano e si sia voglia lo
voglio fare non pensa dopo di questo ma
quasi
raga dove come aiuto gli passò da sopra
sopra se non so come fare questa parte
[Musica]
e non solo ora ghaemi mirato un
consiglio sono stata ma come si fa devo
trovare il verde ma prima gara in questo
era questo li mortacci mi sa che voglio
sempre fare cosa a modo mio
ciao
secondo me c'era una trappola che ho
evitato c'è un punto di salvataggio da
qualche parte per favore può dire c'è
voluto più di quanto pensassi come hai
fatto arrivare qui mi dispiace non
volevo ma è che faccia abbasso la do
veramente fatto che un attimo dove la
mette la gente la webcam in under ten
scusate allora per capire se e dove la
sposto tel
anemone dito per a caso più di pai
vediamo la tengono tutti in alto
la tengono tutti in alto la webcam
purtroppo è strano però perché non so
dove metterla copre qualsiasi cosa
[Musica]
è la terra in alto che vedovi
mi dà fastidio perché copre un po come
dai come hai fatto ad arrivare qui
figlio mio sei ferito chi ti ha fatto
questo è verrai perdonato grazie all
aiuto lasciarti da solo per così tanto
sono stati restii responsabile approval
a sorprenderti comunque grazie a questo
c'è così in questo modo le boe presumo
di non poter nascondere però ancora
tanto vieni piccolino a gesù
rischi view determination news that lo
senti sorpresa batte school cina mumbai
e una cannella cosa il batter scusa è
una torta grazie tale grazia e volevamo
celebrare il tuo arrivo festeggiare tori
grazie e spero che tu passerai un buon
buon tempo vivendo qua beh speriamo non
ho capito niente guardata sorpresa per
te ok ma sono uscito scusa mi dicevi e
questo è chiusa una stanza una stanza
tua spero che ti piaccia
mi è cara
perché lo sta bruciando non è che poi
questa poi diventa cattiva perché è
troppo buona
mi fa troppo strano c'è una cosa che
brucia fai come se fosse casa tua va
bene che bello ho dormito mi andava di
dormire ma io sono troppo tenero hai
trovato un pezzo di torta alla cannella
sono rimesso a dormire
vabbè dai andiamo a farci un giro che
bella questa casa ac l'opzione in
italiano
ma dai sarebbe utile sarebbe figo non
dovrei tradurre al cosa vediamo se
riesco ad attivarla se riesco la prima
anzitutto il menu allora cellulare stat
item
non ci sono azioni italiano per adesso
però magari deve uscire aspettati per
salvare gli orsi che mettono in italiano
peccato perché in inglese in realtà non
è male però life vediamo se le
scommettono in italia nostrano che noi
infatti mi sembra strano non ci fosse
prima vedere 7 insegniamo linguaggio
inglese
no c'è solo in inglese o in cinese
infatti non esiste in italia
cazzate come al solito dalla chat under
the italians grida
[Musica]
no non si può più mettere in italiano
quindi non esiste però va beh vi traduco
io amici mai ascoltare la chat solo
stronzate anche da chi gioca da mertens
vabbè tanto ci stavano a micro pausa
l'ho messo in cinese
meno male che ho saputo ritornare nelle
cose del menu schermi intera mi schermi
in the rami detto ok a farci un giro per
la casina che non ho capito bene dove
siamo
però vabbè giusto regala al bayern
perché questa quest'anno stanza e stanno
ancora facendo usa lo specchio sei tu
beh
[Musica]
oh mio dio cosa sta facendo ma se già
sveglio
[Musica]
volevo farti sapere quanto sono contenta
di avere qualcuno qua ci sono tanti
libri vecchi che voglio condividere e
voglio farti vedere il mio preferito
punto dove cacciare gli insetti
ho preparato un curriculum per la tua
istruzione sono un sacco di sorprese per
te ho sempre voluto essere un insegnante
non è così una sorpresa ma ancora sono
contenta di aver tipo desideravi
qualcosa quando posso andare a casa
no niente poverino non gli diciamo
quando posso andare a casa
bene parla ancora con me se hai bisogno
di qualcosa poverina malaga forino mi
dispiace non voglio dire che vuole dalla
casa poi sembra che non abbia nessuno
porterà iberostar suo canale non mi fa
cagare brown stars è anche forte night
cambi mostre vai su spero 6 giallo
cliccaci ok
quindi passano dal piano di sotto al
piano di sopra e al di sotto
penso che tu debba giocare di sopra ma
dai ma lasciami enrico cosa giocare qua
mafarka vacca prenderà il freddo
continuerà a dirmi frasi così finché non
mi lasciano andare io continuo se ne sta
inventando tutte proprio per non farmi
andare l'ultima volta non c'è niente da
vedere qua cos'è che c'é qua sotto
dai e fastidio che vuoi o ciao puoi
sentire che cosa sto leggendo si chiama
72 usi per snails non so cosa vuol dire
ehi google traduci snails unghie nails
come uscire dalle rovine di sapere
ma cosa vuol dire se ne va bene una
cagata comunque lo sai che snails
a tipo sono insetti sì ma che me ne
frega
come si esce dalle rovine devo fare
qualcosa stai qua
[Musica]
c'è praticamente sta cercano in tutti i
modi divide di armi dal dal voler andare
via
[Musica]
fatto non so dove sia andata quindi
posso andare lì sotto a meno che non sia
andata proprio di sotto vuoi tornare
vuoi desideri di sapere come tornare a
casa vero ha davanti a noi c'è la fine
delle rovine una sola via d'uscita dal a
una sola via d'uscita per il sottosuolo
figo e la sto per distruggere no nessuno
potrà lasciare più questo posto spetta
ora stai drop amine vedi sopra no no no
no no no voi torna a casa
fammi tornare toro maledetto tutti gli
umani che sono venuti qua hanno
incontrato lo stesso destino
l'ho visto ancora e ancora arrivano e se
ne vanno e muoiono
se lascia rovine loro esca re ti
ammazzeranno ti sto solo proteggendo non
mi capi non lo capisci vai alla tua
stanza che non è vero non va dalla mia
stanza maledizione non provare a
fermarmi questo è il tuo ultimo
avvertimento dai vieni naja voglio
uscire no puoi andartene così tanto
allora sei proprio come gli altri c'è
solo una soluzione per tutto questo
provate stesso prova amiche sei
abbastanza forte per sopravvivere no non
è vero non avresti dal man o storie ti
sta bloccando
[Musica]
aiuto talk
non riesci a pensare a nessuna
conversazione nessun argomento di
conversazione come l'audio fa casino si
sente va bene quindi
mamma mia figurati sia
[Musica]
ma sì dai va a cagare e meno mamma mia è
fortissima ma non è possibile
[Musica]
e impossibile mi spaccare legami spacca
di spacca non ce la farò mai
hai pensato a qualcosa da poter dire
ancora ma no eh va beh
ironicamente parlare non sembra essere
la soluzione a questa situazione
la storia prende un respiro profondo e
niente ma è impossibile non puoi farlo
storia il prepara un magico attacco ma è
esondato per non essere spaccato me
n'ero andato non è giusto l'abi sopra
ancora quanto ci vuole per farti
imparare una lezione
[Musica]
la mia vita fa schifo
e impossibile dormire
io volevo uscire da niente sarò di
legato in questo mondo per tutta la vita
lory per favore svegliati se il futuro
dell'umanità e dei mostri che è successo
ancora morendo nome lamis ha recuperato
gli hp
ciao ciao marco ciao gianfry quindi è
tornata è tornato a sedersi a leggere
ancora 18 st
[Musica]
ma ancora questa è sparita io me ne sono
andato come i bambini sopra quindi dove
che se volevo fare studiato ancora qua
ad ora ha distrutto se però stai qua
tutta la vita posso devo fare io penso
avesse distrutto madonna ma ti spacco il
culo
non è vero non e spacco il culo mi
spacca lei paga impossibile troppa vita
parlare non serve a niente
[Musica]
sono stato bravissimo dai se riuscissi a
schivarla un pelo di più forse riesco
no è possibile scherzavano fanno eva fa
troppo danno qualche cosa fate cagata
minchia figura metà vita gli ho tolto ma
neanche
[Musica]
meta sta adesso figura
porca vacca che male
[Musica]
beh però daino fatto l'ho fatto per lo
schifo schifo
[Musica]
se per caso dovessi scrivere tutte
ap angola
però non mi sta più da quando come prima
mi sta allevando molto meno
[Musica]
attenzione
l'ho fatta fuori
che cazzo ci voglio levato 33 142 grazie
skeet arran do un bacio e appena riesco
passo promis l'elevato 342 pensavo mi
facesse fuori lei
sei forte di quanto più di quanto
pensassi ascolta di piccolo se vai
dietro questa porta continua a camminare
più che puoi raggiungere riuscito che
asghar e non lasciare che a score e
prende la tua anima il suo piano non non
deve avere successo che mi spiace che
dome alle mie navi si buono
figlio mio
dovevo risparmiarla mi menava ragazzi io
chi mi venne allo strumenti c'è non è
colpa mia e che se stava ferma sto fermo
9 cazzo carica
poi ho provato a parlare non imparava
poi s'è andato a dormire lettonia
visionarle dove vado a dormire ma
detenere soggiornato ancora la stava
allora promuove che mimì miei misti gli
proprio al gore a gara le schiere dove
scorso silenzio
mimì e spero che ti piace la tua scelta
dopotutto non è che puoi tornare
indietro e cambiare il tuo destino in
questo mondo è uccidere o essere ucciso
ha provato così tanto a salvarmi umani
ma quando è scesa qui sotto e non è
saputo salvare neanche se stessa che
idiota
addirittura
macché
ah ok pensavo fosse finito dice ma
trovato
[Musica]
che figata al suo posto dove che siamo
sentite una porta aprirsi
ragazzi beppe c'è un ponte bellissimo
umano non lo sai come pulp cosa vuol
dire pall
non sai come presentarti grid un nuovo a
mio amico immagino sia palo e credo
girati e stringevano cioè shake shake
tema fratello
[Musica]
mamma mia che simpatico questo wow è che
il vecchio trucco il cuscino nella mano
ciao mamma mia mamma mia sto ridendo
spagna
se non vanno si è così divertente
anzi su science science the skeleton a
dare un'occhiata agli umani ad es
ma lo sai non mi piace prendermi cura di
nessuno
[Musica]
ora fratello papirus è un calciatore di
umani fanatico
e attualmente penso che che sta laggiù
non ho idea
attraverso eroe attrezza questo che un
cancello
ok poi attraverso a sia fatto le sbarre
troppo larghe per stoppare qualcuno il
mio libro
complimenti normale che non un'idea
prigioni devo andare dietro quella con
la lampada anche per fermi nasconde
perfettamente sacro ma che sarebbe
papirus papyrus pie pires come xvi si
legge papirus papyrus come skyrim
papyrus sono state sono otto giorni e
ancora non hai ricalibrato i tuoi enigmi
e puzzle e nei sei solo fuori dalla tua
stazione che cosa stai facendo
sto fissando questa lampada mi sembra
molto cool
vuoi dare un'occhiata no non ho tempo
per questo che cosa succede se un umano
arriva fino qua voglio essere pronto
voglio essere sarò il prescelto
devo essere presenti catturerà un umano
e poi io il grande papirus
avrò tutte le cose che io merito
rispetto
ma perché va scusami perché il
catturarono ammalerebbe dati rispetto a
te perché sei integratore va bene e
sottosuolo sarà finalmente in grado di
far parte della guardia imperiale le
persone che faranno domande per essere
miei dove andranno di essere miei amici
[Musica]
farò sempre bagno di una doccia è una
doccia di baci tutte le mattine
[Musica]
magari questa lampada può aiutarti se
solo avessi ascoltato ma stai aiutando
sans nous [ __ ] pido pigro tutt'ossa
tutto quello che fai e bighellonare e
diventare sempre più pigro e pigro ogni
giorno ei the kaye jay ho un sacco
scritto in giallo non so perché di
lavoro da fare sono uno scheletro ma va
a cagare ragazzi cosa sto cercando cosa
è così ti cos'è io lo adoro questo qui è
un genio a ti frego e il genio lo amo il
fantastico suns è un po mi rispecchia un
sacco come persona suns andiamo stai
sorridendo sto sorridendo e l'odio
[Musica]
perché qualcuno grande come me deve fare
così tanto per prendere un po di
riconoscimento ragazzini nostro
calendario di 4 secondi scusatemi mi
passerà stop ayelet influenza no ho
sbagliato e non l'ho capita scusami
hanno sbagliato sori stavano peccato è
che non l'ho capito aspetterò i puzzle
[Musica]
dati da fare male detto d'accordo
ok mi piace un sacco unque suns è è
tornato a niente puoi venire fuori
adesso
ok sei simpatico
[Musica]
potrebbe tornare potrebbe tornare dietro
se lo fa di sederti attraverso più degli
altri miei temi e barzellette scherzetti
cazzo 16 in italia
e la frase prima che comunque non ho
capito non l'ultimo
a ciò li huei potresti farmi mi dispiace
dati fastidio proprio per si farmi un
favore
sto pensando aveva mai visto il mio
fratello era un aveva in mano prima e
vederti potrebbe rallegrarlo per tutta
la giornata potrebbe make my day è una
roba in inglese non sono italiani
non ti preoccupare non è pericoloso
anche se ci prova
grazie mille ok che dovrebbe essere
proprio qua sopra ma non ho capito devo
qui andrà incontra il fratello perché
suo fratello non ha mai visto né umano e
non renderebbe felice se mi devo
ritornare tutti indietro per andare al
fratello che poi le quanto rado lunga
strada ho visto cos'era ho vista una
roba qua giuro ma grazie andrew anche so
much ma non ho capito dove dovrebbe
essere dai che fanno far anti indietro
[Musica]
non riesce a cambiare la lingua no
esiste solo in inglese e in cinese
le versioni italiano c'erano prima della
nuova patch adesso non si può più
mettere in tasca luca fine doveva andare
avanti c'era quello è tornato indietro
ma dovevo andare avanti o tu sorella
designs questa è una scatola puoi
mettere gli oggetti dentro e prendere
gli oggetti la stessa scatola apparirà
come i residenti vo ok si un amante
delle scatole firmato un amante delle
scatole a posso mettere il battiscopa a
tanto c'è un guanto che ho preso porca
vacca poteva fare un po di active dai
giochi
[Musica]
io mi capita ai spam
dovrebbe essere divertente non lo so non
so che cosa voglia dire pan prima di
farlo
pronto a fare le stesse cose solo
prevedere se a mi dice semplicemente che
l'ha già sentita ok ma se tu non
combatti nemici non la prendi
l'esperienza verso qua è un tipo
incazzato a prescindere se non puoi fare
niente si stia male
hai detto al questo qua che nessuno liam
era nella loro forma di come sono fatti
hai vinto vabbè ovvero il poverino
grazie ribat c'è una canna da pesca
fissa sul terreno dove tirare
no ho sbagliato più capo chiamami questo
il mio numero 10 di non chiamarla chi
aveva parlato e pesce valori messo in
atto vabbè porca vacca mi sa che mi
scoprono quindi quello che stavo dicendo
riguardo un dinner park al h cioè si
stanno guardando a vicenda
geniale questa cosa salse o mio dio
quello è un umano
[Musica]
attualmente penso che sia una roccia
veramente penso siano roccia a è che
cos'è che la roba davanti alla roccia o
mio dio è un umano si o mio dio suns
finalmente ce l'ho fatta
11 un diner io diventerò sarò popolare
popolare popolare umano 1 riuscendo a
spazi fantasmi dei tool non puoi passare
in quest'area il grande papà eros che ti
stop era sì c'è papà i russi immagine
perché la ypsilon e tipo skyrim quindi
papyrus
il gruppo pires dista però egli ai preti
caturano e sarai inviato alla capitale e
poi e poi io non so sicuri cosa
succederà dopo
ma in ogni caso continua solo se i
feeder prova provaci cioè nel senso se
voi ci vuoi provare non vedenti e non so
bene l'inglese
beh è andata bene non sudare ma mi terrò
un occhio per te che ti terrò d'occhio
già tutti lo chiamiamo papirus perché
non sappiamo in inglese ma tu sei
l'unico che lo pronuncia giusto si dice
papà io so lo so che sia papa e roda y
maletas come io leggevo scheme quando
ero piccolo quando le recensioni di
skyrim skirring papyrus ring ring ei sta
in funzione il tuo refrigerato il tuo
figlio frigo sì
[Musica]
brioschi non so cosa voglia dire voglio
voglio depositarsi le brioche kiss sarà
qualcosa da mettere nel frigo non si
bachi e camicie ste cose qua e là suns
che pirla questo è un pokémon
complimento ignora complimenti
faccio complimenti li informo che ha un
bel cappello a chi è che non lo sa
sì ma stai calmo che ti faccio un culo
che la metà basta ignora ruba hai
provato a rubargli il cappello ma nome
non ci credo
tensione ci prova questo qua ignora
[Musica]
niente continua non c'è modo di farlo
cedere ragazzi dominarlo anche lui o
insisto allora mi avete detto a bruschi
se la medicina per il raffreddore chiaro
dicevo mi avete detto devi continuare a
fargli i complimenti o quelle robe
russell vedi che non cedono subito io
adesso ci provo se non funziona
io da adesso in avanti disintegro tutti
quelli che mi capitano a tiro
perché voi mi avete eletto di continuare
attiva complimentarmi per il suo
cappello
giuro che se mi avete una cagata che non
fosse non funziona io faccio genocidio
invidioso e continuativi che bello il
cappello che mi dice che sono invidiosi
[Musica]
non ho sbagliato
beh
niente ragazzi non funziona il genocidio
l'hack è male che male basta mi ha rotto
le palle sei ore di cose
[Musica]
ma devo fare mercy è vero o no ma io non
posso fare subito mercy è vero ma io non
posso farlo subito
[Musica]
aveva niente la possibilità per papyrus
ad ora abbiamo capito e dice chissà chi
è che l'ha costruita col font di files
[Musica]
non muoverti c'è un cane qualcosa si è
mosso è stata la mia immaginazione
posso solo vedere le cose che si muovono
sapevo cosa si muove ad esempio un umano
farò in modo che non si muova mai più
dog blocks the way
vabbè dog eat dog stesso spiccio sparire
il movimento no no no
ah ok se sto fermano mi colpisce fetta
di nuovo gli oggetti dog ha funzionato
si passa che sto fermo lo vivo niente
spetta ancora questa scopi from e gli
sta piacendo
non c'è fine a tutto questo ma posso
farlo ancora per molto oppure devo fare
mercy
che carino a fermarsi a quando il mare
lo mele è mosso giallo uso merse
something that means ampi da lei sloveni
ma cosa mi qualche cosa sto dice ho
bisogno di trattamenti da cane per
questo sì però non ha capito cosa se c'è
dell'osso qua ragazzi non ho parole o
suns ei c'è qualcosa di importante da
ricordare è il mio fratello è un a un
attacco veramente speciale se vedi un
attacco blu non muoverti e non ti farà
niente
è un modo facile per tenerlo in
meramente immaginali immaginati un
fermano un segnale di stop
quando vedi un segnale di stop ti fermi
giusto segnale di stop sono verdi quindi
immaginate un segnale di stop blu
semplice vero quando combatti appensa i
segnali di stop
ok ma perché tutto questo
nord su 2 istituto ice ice made in town
and high heels ovviamente ma sono un
segnale
volevo vedere il mondo ma non posso
muovermi
potresti essere così gentile viaggiatore
per favore di prendere un pezzo di me
portarlo molto lontano certo ma che
bello va bene che lo porta lontano lo
porto sei così pigro ma basta dirgli che
pigro povero cristo è infatti un
pisolino tutta la notte
penso che quello sia chiamato dormire mi
scusi mi scusi e scusami scusami scuse
scuse in generale onorario l'umano modo
da per poi fermarti [ __ ]
io e mio fratello abbiamo creato ama il
fratello e lui
[Musica]
non ho capito si riferiva papyrus come
fratello
pensavo che lo chiamasse pro della serie
high brow ma lambro fosse veramente il
suo fratello però effettivamente ci può
stare sono due scheletri il mio fratello
io abbiamo creato dei puzzle
credo che troverai questo qua un po
scioccante per vederlo per the
invisibile ed è un labirinto di
elettricità
quando tocchi muri di questo labirinto
questo questa palla farà uno zac di
elettricità sono divertente perché è la
quantità di divertimento e probabilmente
avrai che non sarà molta penso ma che
puoi andare adesso va bene
effettivamente ce l'hai tu la palla
quindi suns che cosa hai fatto
pensavo che lo amano dovesse avere la
padre
adesso me la dà
[Musica]
prendi questa per favore ok prova adesso
incredibile mamma mia ragazza io non ho
parola viggiù l'ha risolta così
facilmente troppo facilmente comunque il
prossimo passo non sarà così facile ed è
stato disegnato la mia fratello suns
sicuramente sarai confuso spiegamenti ei
grazie mio fratello sembra che sia
scaricate in avevo capito che la sua
fratello che pirla
hai visto comunque quella outfit strano
che sta indossando abbiamo fatto qualche
settimane fa per una festa in costume
[Musica]
non ha avuto problemi finché non hanno
continuato a chiamarlo la africa non ha
continuato a chiamarlo il suo corpo da
battaglia
[Musica]
ahimè non è lennon è col mio fratello
beh più o meno chi è questa altro non
capisco perché questi non si vendono è
la temperatura perfetta per qualcosa di
freddo o un cliente ei vuoi prendere un
ice cream knysna e mamma mia
sì sì voglio un ice cream è in programma
il maestro arrivo grazie per in ice
scream ice cream stop cos'è spiegami
vabbè a devo mettere la palla in buca
fermi tutti cristiano ronaldo no no no
si sta gelando porca vacca non ce la
farò mai sicuri che la devo mettere in
bocca non ce la farò mai
porco schifo a destra e niente non ce
l'ha fatta da chi se ne frega è
ritornato aspetta che ci prova di
metterla
non so cosa serva sta roba in realtà
o che palle ma parco demoni riesci ad
andare tutte diagonale nelle scommettono
in diagonale perfetto grazie quindi
anche quando senti ti senti tra parato
[Musica]
prendi le note ai archiviato la fine
della pausa
sei stato ricompensato di due g il
gelato lo il nice scrima l'ho pagato 15
e dico solo quello
questo ma suns non era di sopra scusami
umano spero che tu sia pronto per i clan
sacco del taro nisticò de sass dov'è il
puzzle è proprio qui sul pavimento
credimi non c'è modo in cui possa
passare questo
[Musica]
a è uno di quei casi dove devi trovare
le parole crociate croce veramente
ma come faccio a sud
scusatemi non c'ho voglia false non l'ha
fatto niente pensavo di avere utilizzato
la le parole crociate di oggi cosa le
parole crociate
non credo che tu non ci credo che ti ha
detto questa roba
nella mia opinione junior jumbor non so
cosa voglia dire
penso sia il nome di una sfida è
facilmente la più difficile
cosa davvero quella parola dati easy
peasy world scramble a quale solo per
bambini per bambini o incredibile umano
i soldi questa disputa che cos'è che è
più duro jumbo lo crossword che la sua
voi due siete strani le parole crociate
sono così facili
adesso sempre la stessa soluzione ogni
volta solo devi completare solo le
caselle con la lettera z perché ogni
volta di qua delle parole crociate tutto
quello che posso fare se nord sono lì e
non mi ricordo il nord non mi sono più
no vuol dire
[Musica]
a russare perché lui le capisce ciao
antonella grazie mille
proverò a fare child of light thank you
quali sono le parole crociate più belle
che abbiamo visto complimenti suns
papyrus trova difficoltà imposte
interessanti salviamo stai lavorando
troppo riducendo all'osso non stai
dicendo suns è molto figo
mi piace molto mi piace tantissimo
[Musica]
avete dei commenti per tutto quello che
è successo fino adesso
dai facciamo tipo a pando vuol dire
barzelletta jock cosa vuol dire scherzo
facciamo tipo una micro dibattito c'è
qualcosa che c'è considerazioni
considerazioni un minuto di
considerazioni poi continuiamo stata
data quando finisce tra un'oretta fisco
alle a mezzanotte
[Musica]
ciò significa scherzetto ci sono devi
insistere parlando con l'avversario
l'unica roba che poi devi fare mercy ok
suns e grasso a me sta piacendo molto
non devi uccidere toria mi picchiava e
l'ho ucciso
[Musica]
grazie a te sta imparando un sacco di
inglese alcune parole che ci sono
difficilissime altri paesi non ci riesce
no no io ho un problema che c'ero anche
nella vita reale che alcune parole io
non so cosa significò gioc
io so che cosa significa in inglese ma
non saprei tradurlo in italiano c'è so
che quando prendi per il culo la persona
da 13 gen giorgio era solo uno scherzo
che però non saprei tradurlo in italiano
c'è perché gioca e scherzetti scherzi in
questo caso infatti un esempio le rende
le palle però ci sono state parole in
cui io cioè che io leggendo l'inglese ho
capito tutto ma a volte non so trovare
la parola in italiano di quello che sto
leggendo a volte a va capita che non
capisco proprio
però è raro però a volte non so tradurre
della singola parola perché solo cosa
voglia dire in inglese prova a farlo in
cinese allora sì perfetto ma gli avanzi
pensavo considerazione più strane
[Musica]
noi vi lasciate ucciderà ti ho capito ma
mic ma picchiato l'ho picchiata cosa
dovevo fare
non lo so d'altrone che dici vabbè
tauriel ai picchiata a sangue no provato
a fare hack thing 800 volte me ne son
pure andato hanno certo dato dato a
dormire ma ha detto van dormire soldato
a dormire è detto sotto naturali che
dovevo fare gara pd così averci scritto
in testa fatti uccidere perché più di
così non so poi era pure difficile
pensavo mi facesse fuori invece no a lei
vuol dire lo marca grazie a questa ad
esempio non lo sapevo
[Musica]
ok
continuiamo raga dato in attimo e molto
mi piace molto soprattutto le musiche mi
piacciono proprio tanto sono fatte bene
e fatto tutto bene quindi se ci sta non
esiste un modo sbagliato di giocare poi
fare qualsiasi cosa si lo so
in realtà tutta tutti i fanatici di
under the scrivono sempre robe tipo a
fai così fai kosai iwata non c'è proprio
questo il bello di n3 che non c'è ma è
giusto qualsiasi cosa tu faccia è un
gioco che prende immagazzina proprio
quello che quello che c'è nella tua
anima nella tua volontà di di giocare
rende il gioco tuo quindi io non posso
giocarlo in nel modo di un altro gioco
nel modo mio come fare io le cose quindi
io in questa situazione avrei fatto
fuori i tower
io per come sono fatto tu non lo so ed è
proprio questo il bello di under the che
ognuno lo gioca a modo suo e non sono
quei giochi che stanno su dei binari i
singoli che su questo
wow wow arrivo datemi un attimo
[Musica]
allora direi che possiamo ricominciare
conoscere il mouse un topo potrebbe una
volta trovare un
una maniera per scaldare gli spaghetti
ok it feels so good termination si
riempie di determinazione trovare gli
spaghetti
vabbè al quale up che ci sono gli
spaghetti l'avevo visto neanche che non
gli spaghetti per me non è che si
capisca proprio ciao crispa da ciao a te
a rachele fi over voci non penso cioè
che la kingdom hearts iii si fa vj
selvatico in live
offriamo il caffè bacio palidoro da un
bacio davide
ciao rosso alessandro ciao re campo ciao
fernando ciao alejandro
un piatto di infront di gli spaghetti
freddi che schifo
egli ha attaccato al tavolo e poi c'è il
microonde all the settings 6 spaghetti
perché non posso prendere gli spaghetti
perché sono attaccati al tavolo da
becker peccato
a meno che non posso usare ma gli
oggetti vi posso usare io sono i
fratelli prendere col guanto
va beh posso usare posso scaldare la
torta
no l'ho mangiata volevo mettere il
microonde l'ho mangiata capirla
attenzione matrimonio di cani cosa ho
appena letto
juan ha ricevuto lessard o capirci a pet
pet troppi pezzi a malapena alzato la
mano è il cane si è citato punt plant
perché no vabbè ragazzi c'è la cosa più
tenera del mondo sto male 7 per mercy
mercy mercy mercy meraviglioso però la
domanda mia ma io posso fare emersi a
prescindere anche senza far act giusto è
vertice o già subito io cos'è sta roba
qua è una mappa è una mappa che ti segna
dove il cosa per aprire le punte che sta
esattamente
qua testa suicide ok c'è c'è un uno
switch ecco suicidi italiano questi c'è
suicide so cos'è uno switch però in
italiano non saprei leva ragazze di
interruttore cavolo ecco acceso sto
problema siete cani
cos'è cos'è quell'odore cose volatore
identificati identifiers melfi alcune
non le puoi tradurre sipra state calmi
c'è un odore strano un impiano e ne
voglia di eliminare eliminarti d'oggi
assolti
[Musica]
prego che li prego nintendo interruttore
la switch effettivamente l'interruttore
doga mie dogaressa bene vedi dei livelli
ad esempio vedi io posso già fare emersi
a no ok
porca va e va bene un potevi non potevi
assolutamente evitarla
quindi non può non puoi non puoi far
emersi subito
ok non puoi far emersi subito
no game that i cani sono troppo
sospettosi del tuo odore
[Musica]
ahia non puoi giocare logo il joystick e
difficilissimo schivare qui tasti
direzionali ris
riri annusa i cani annusano ma il tuo il
tuo odore e strano proprio come prima
porca vacca
[Musica]
l'all around ttt rotoli per terra nella
neve e odori come uno strano cucciolo ok
quindi forse stavolta sollecita a
distrarli perché ho d'oro diversamente
la prima adesso posso fare sniff bank
dopo che ti sei rotolato il tuo odore è
tutto ok ok viene adesso posso fare
mercy no non posso fare mercy porco
demonio porco
act dogaressa are all around
forse perché devo farlo anche quando
chiarezza probabilmente un macello ex
dogaressa resmini sa lo sanno tutti e
due i mimi odore allora non rompete le
balle
cosa volete qualche casino a è vero il
cui i blues sono quindi dovevo stare
fermo chiaro bello grazie alla fed logan
essa porta about me è vero quelli blu se
stai fermo non ti colpiscono che figo a
dogmi cat
ok allora l'ho fatto ho fatto tutto voi
devo fare porca vacca nel mecca è
difficile lo stesso anche qui con i blue
mercy
secondo me quando il mercy e giallo lo
puoi fare i cani possono
pet so cosa vuol dire però in italiano
non saprei di a mais pet un animale
borloo sorega non solo italiano perché
l'inglese un nuovo mondo si è aperto per
noi grazie strano cucciolo prego
[Musica]
trasforma hicks in 10 e premi in
territorio come faccio a sei tasti a
playstation scusa come ho fatto a
cambiarli scusa mente non ho capito a
papyrus come hai fatto a voi da girare
la mia trappola cosa più importante cioè
qualcosa di diverso che cosa per me
negli spaghetti e gli ho lasciato
davvero wow ha resistito al sapore della
mia pasta cucinata in casa la power che
non conosci mia nonna così potresti con
di pare solo per condividere perché
avesse voluto condividerla con me ecco
questo non solo sul freddo è noto non
solo io maestro chef papyrus ti farò ti
farò tutta la pasta che tu vorrai è
grazie papyrus sa veramente come
ringraziare aspetta tac
grazie cream
[Musica]
87 significato messico non solo
significa maestrale significa
accarezzare un cane quella significa
tante cose sarebbero animale domestico
sì ma significa diverse cose per quello
ma a volte non so tradurlo spetta al dog
non vuol dire che lo prendi e l'udc
reillo di vai diventare domestico livelo
stai anche accarezzando quindi vuol dire
dipende dal contesto
cosa fanno mi caga più mio fratello
iniziato una collezione di calze
recentemente quanto triste
[Musica]
cosa vuol dire ma perché
ma perché tutto questo perché è iniziata
una collezione di calze perché deve
essere triste ma vero il ma lascialo
stare non so io a voi perché accudire
esatto tante rho avevo di a volte mi
chiedo che cosa farebbe senza un ragazzo
così col che si prende cura di lui e non
te ne vai stavolta ho fatto amicizia con
papyrus umano come posso dirlo
ci ha messo così tanto da arrivare
quindi ho deciso di fare un implementare
improve miglioramento dei puzzle
riarrangiando la neve per farla
somigliare di più alla mia faccia
sfortunatamente la neve si ebbe
ghiacciata al terremoto ora una
soluzione diversa è come sempre mi
obbligò il mio pigro fratello è in giro
nel lower porca vacca come cose anche
nowhere come però tra due nauer nessuno
[Musica]
adesso la pa non lo so che si dice
italiano ai sul posto la danese è
prevista dicendo è non ti preoccupare
umano
il grande papyrus ecco conundrum il suo
sodo e poi possiamo procedere nel
frattempo sentiti libero di risolvere il
puzzle preconto ricetta per conto tuo
proverò a non darti la risposta ok come
prima admo premere ok c'è cagata più o
meno l'aspetta mai pensare stai
lavorando i miei pensieri incredibili
porca vacca non è così facile questa
allora alla ora
[Musica]
cavolo questo non è stupido va beh vi
faccio vedere come come volevo farla io
però non funziona così però poi sei
costretto a passare sugli altri non va
quindi rischia cioè lo switch ciao cree
conoscerò tuo padre per tori ma io vivo
a milano
porca vacca però vabbè se vengo a torino
spero anch'io un bacio thank you so much
era rimasto scusate ma ben chiaro né
facile questa finalmente la roba
difficile
[Musica]
allora secondo me
ah sì
[Musica]
passi ok e pirla e la morte perché mi
ero fatto dei pensieri chissà chissà
quale quanto stupidi mai fatta senza mi
aiuti incredibile sono impressionato ti
piace melini che faccio allora quindi
sicuro che il tuo amore per i sono
sicuro del tumore per gli iniqui deve
essere anche stato troppo facile per te
eh eh eh mi piace la sua risata o
figurati quando parla incredibile 2 già
console di inizio a cui i tuoi moratti o
lavora per ha valorizzato velocemente
non è neanche avuto bisogno del mio
aiuto
ok che è fantastico perché io amo non
fare assolutamente nulla io lo adoro
sono io quello lì sono io sono io
io sono lui bella non ho mai giocato
l'andata il suo seguito l'attore con
gusto grazie scesi julie anche io non ho
mai giocando dal giocato dante a terra
ed è veramente gustoso i tristi ma basta
enigmi e l'umano amerai questo bucks
abili artita fare i puzzle è stato fatto
alla grande da tor papyrus scusa sito
vedrai queste setimes
queste cose striscia una volta che
ricevo di età il suo una volta che
azione rojo l'interruttore e diventa
cambieranno colore ogni colore alla
differente funzione quelle rosse non
fanno niente cipe camminare quelle
gialle sono elettriche e ti faranno male
quelle verde sono quelle verdi farà non
sono allarmi e se ci andrai sopra dovrei
combattere un mostro quelle arancioni
sono arancione e ti faranno dorare in
modo delizioso quelle blu sono di acqua
e poi nuotarci però solo se a sedurre
gli arancioni piranha di mordano e
comunque quelle blu sono vicino a quelle
gialle
anzi sono vicino a quelle gialle la
l'acqua di altri fichera mica quanta
roba quelle viole sono slippery non so
dove dire ah ok e scivolose andare su
quella successiva comunque in quella il
sapone sa di limone e al limone non
piace piranha quindi viola e blu sono ok
finalmente quelle vie basta quanta roba
a quelle rosa loro non fanno niente
starci sopra quanto vuoi questo è tutto
è capito non mi ricordo più niente se
great l'ultima cosa questo puzzle è
completamente random quando tiro questa
interruttore farò un puzzle che non ho
mai visto prima
neanche io saprò la soluzione è
[Musica]
sei pazzo ma va a cagare va non mi
ricordavo più niente no ragazzi ora io
non io non non ce la faccio non sono io
come ho fatto a non giocare sta roba
come ho fatto come ho fatto a non
giocare ad under the hill prima meno
male perché non mi ricordavo una sega
gli spaghetti di prima non erano così
male
per mio fratello da quando ha preso
lezioni di cucina è migliorato molto
spero che continui
[Musica]
ho capito cosa voglia dire di ball
quindi tradotto fatto prima c'è un cane
che lecca una roba filzi with
termination ciao questo cane sta
fissando la neve sta aspettando che che
diventi un un'opera d'arte
il cane tifosi quel scale si considera
un artista e non sa neanche che cosa
creare proprio mettere un aiuto che il
suo cervello è grande quanto un pezzo di
chiba una roba molto probabimente
piccola o dai e ragazzi sembrano dei
limiti di pokémon no che pirla che pirla
c'era stato a distanza da eddy papais
trasla verso la penalità
c'è che l'ha fatta che pirla sono
cascato dalla fine
[Musica]
cosa c'è scusate a chi è stupido c'è
roba fatta già la prima la prima botta
sull'uscita ca del bue volte hai mai
giocato a the forest no melo consigli
[Musica]
cos'è
ma una piccola casa per cani da caccia o
gesù cristo come van den za sembrava
tenero the greater dog mi piace la
musica che c'è ok spera quando diventa
giallo lo posso cliccar e pet
evitandogli stufara way to get gli
aspetti in di era accarezzi l'aria passa
dormendo lo fa niente marc barr che
creda doc ha svettato comando lei e noi
non è citato con di giocare con te ma
porca vacca
l'hack è male pezzente schifoso back
home chiavi non ho capito cosa è
successo in realtà però ignora pet play
cosa manca il cane si avvicina che
adesso posso fare pet porca vacca il bar
che forte cat
beh non ho capito che è successo però
s'è addormentato e si è svegliato e che
così eccitato bells e forse possiamo non
posso far emersi non posso fare mercy
porca vacca
aia signore
ap devo fare ignora e tante volte va
bene più come la spiega ma basta aiuto
con signori tante volte inizia burkhart
in faccia ma posso fare adesso mercy
stiamo a fare in ritardo che decide che
tu sei troppo noioso
hai vinto vabbè lo so cosa ho visto
[Musica]
guarda non avevo dubbi umano questa è la
tua finale è più pericolosa sfida
attenzione spiega un trader later
mamma mia c'è un cane la destra non hai
visto quando dinho la parola si attiverà
pieno regime i cannoni spariranno le
spine spingeranno le
le lame affitteranno ogni parte di swing
era forte violentemente solo la più
piccola probabilità di vittoria rimarrà
sei pronto perché io perché sto per
farlo ok fanno non lo fa beh tutto
quest'attesa attesa posso attivare anche
adesso
[Musica]
non mi sembrano molto attive bene questa
sfida sembra troppo facile per per
sconfiggere l'umano non possiamo usarla
sono uno scheletro con degli standard i
miei enigmi sono molto fair
sapete cosa vuol dire fair play fate due
più due e le vie trappole sono preparate
in modo esperto ma questo metodo è
troppo diretto non ha classe dopo tutto
e quindi se ne va bene
a chi stai guardando era un'altra
decisiva la vittoria per papà io non so
che non so ma soprattutto a far a mio
fratello adesso se fossi in te io starei
attento agli attacchi blu
ok benvenuti has now di una città ce lo
shop figo
elogio a vedere come posso aiutarti o
posso comprare delle robe bandana bisi
così non posso vendere le robe clip da
non posso vedere scherzi maestà 80 non
c'è un intero no alla scatola che posso
mentre cento la roba però non mi serve
al giorno
minchia 80g ma vaffan tua sorella
manco morto cg ci dormo qua
[Musica]
vabbè quante grossa sta città ragazzi
che figata è tutto chiuso dove che si
può andare fair prego dire gioca pulito
si e firewall dire corretto tipo giusto
cosa succede aiuto fa troppo freddo sto
morendo papyrus umano
fammi fatti raccontare poi riguardo dei
sentimenti complessi sentimenti come la
gioia di trovare un'altra amante della
pasta l'ammirazione per un altro enigma
risoluto risolto con skills talenti il
desiderio di avere una persona cool è
intelligente che pensi che tu sia curva
questi sentimenti queste sensazioni sono
quelle che devi sentire adesso tu possa
immaginare difficilmente ci si debba
sentire sentirsi come debba essere
sentiti in quel modo dopo tutto io sono
i grandi sono veramente grande non
immagina che cosa significa avere un
sacco di amici riti porca vacca
pitino mi ricordo che cosa voglia dire
porca vacca pt l'ho letto stamattina
mentre giocava metal gear mannaia pt che
cosa voleva dire pt nodo stampare in
testa pt meters pietà si è quello che
pensavo perché pensavo fosse mercy pieta
forse vi vogliamo dire ho pietà dite
solo umano ma non solo
non sarai più non ti preoccupare non
sarai solo più io il grande papa e lo
sarò il tuo no no tutto questo è
sbagliato non posso essere tuo amico 61
mano devo catturarti quindi posso
soddisfare il mio
il mio sogno di una vita il potere la
popolarità il prestigio questo è papyrus
il nuovo membro della guardia reale
[Musica]
proviamo a far acting vediamo se non mi
costringe a farlo a pezzi flirt cosa
flirtare quindi veramente di riferito i
sentimenti i tuoi ultimi o ultimate
sentiment ultimi definiti sentimenti
definitivi sono uno scheletro con dave
degli alti standard
io posso fare gli spaghetti anche
michael o no sai contorno agli standard
quindi significa possa andare un
appuntamento con te possiamo darci un
appuntamento dopo prima ti devo
catturare beh non era così difficile
come attacco flirt
dai del lei ti va bene
[Musica]
insulta
puoi farmi sentire meglio per quanto
riguarda combattere con te grazie lucky
samsa dormendo da otto ore
se si sveglia si se no ma non penso
perché sta dormendo vedo penso che non
si sveglierà mai conoscendo non l'ho mai
visto sveglio a quest'ora si tormenta
tipo alle 9 non ho letto se usate non
miri merito con l'ospitalità da parte
tua narrava del genere quindi non vuoi
combattere
vediamo se poi per resistere al mio
attacco blu malaga mai scarsissimo
papyrus cioè lo vedo strà schiva bile
fino ad ora ai ha ora sei tu questo è
mio attacco è casa
[Musica]
ragazzi quindi vuol dire che se io sono
blu posso schivare no non schifo ok va
bene
[Musica]
porca vacca che scarsa insulta papyrus
ha continuato basta meno tre palle ai a
niente sembra il giochino quello di
google chrome quando non c'è internet
iniziato a diventare difficile
[Musica]
no
lista raga non funziona che palle
e vabbè
[Musica]
papyrus doubs mtt brand jack
mi piace c'era scritto gli piace dire
niente la risata che fare i soldi parcak
che botta niente ragazzi ho provato a
[Musica]
ragazzi mi spacca si continua ad
apparecchi thing muoio e poi lo rifaccio
lo ammazzo perché c'è ma a quanto pare
risparmiare non serve una sega
almeno non conta quello di artù e sei
troppo debole e stato troppo semplice
catturati solo perché non ha deciso di
spaccarsi la faccia amico mio se non
avrei niente mi si è impigliato il
computer è successo è successo e cosa ti
manderò nella capsula sean o come senza
la chiama il tuo gara il nostro garage
se nella casetta dei cani adesso la
cuccia miei quindi non sono morto
perché convinto che lei che se le sbarre
siano così larghe 1 non ci passi perché
una nota da papyrus scusa se mi ha
dovuto chiudersi nella stanza degli
ospiti finché non arriva online
senti libero di fare come se fossi a
casa tua
rinfresco e accomodation sono stati
messi a disposizione ma sempre in folli
horse papa e lo spread fatto quindi
adesso non c'è più ma l'ho passato c'è
ma io mi ha detto mi sono liberata mag
ora basta
dove può essere andato con l'umano avevo
davanti a me
aspetto il secondo non dovevi scappare
torna indietro basta
che palle
mi chiamo lo spacco mi sono rotto
cosa devo fare più di così lo spacco ora
ricevuto
ai seriamente perso contro papa no non
ho perso contro paris mi dicono tutti i
parenti
quindi ho fatto acting un'ora e mezza e
alla fine niente mi ha ucciso lo stesso
quindi gli spaccare la faccia volentieri
però ho perso perché o dopo voluto
perdere ma non serve a niente a quanto
pare
fai mercy ok ma non funziona incredibile
non me lo sarei mai aspettato papyrus
pensa di continuo a fare mercy però la
musica è bella
[Musica]
c'è chi continuando a fare mercy
papyrus spruzza un po di colonia iosco
la colonia profumo di ossa dietro il suo
orecchio
ok la fragranza di ossa
[Musica]
aia appaiono non se la testa delle royal
guardia ed c'è il capo della guardia
[Musica]
un par alle parallele spaghetto re
spaghetto re cosa vuol dire aia
[Musica]
ha sbagliato ok è nettamente facile in
realtà non detto semplicemente
ci sta mettendo solo una vita e ora ga
più segue i vostri consigli più fare il
contrario ce l'avrei spaccato subito la
fa al primo incontro avrei mai aspettato
così tanto però va bene
[Musica]
devo continuare tanto
non hai pazienza fida tv risultati poi
arriva ok
sono le 11 e 40 se entro mezzanotte
quindi o 20 minuti di mercy non fa
niente lo ammazzo o 20 minuti diversi
sono tante
[Musica]
la cosa la cosa la cosa che mi dispiace
è che io lo avrei spaccato subito se
fosse stato per me avrei ucciso
immediatamente solo che continua a dirmi
tutti non ucciderlo ma io lo ucciderei
super volentieri ciro ammazzare subito
perché c'è buona che possono ultima a
morire
[Musica]
questa è l'ultima volta che provo simons
e mi fa fuori un'altra volta poi lo
ammazzo
[Musica]
praga la musica è bellissima non so
perché mi piace il botto
[Musica]
che sfiga
c'era scritto papyrus da marinara dalla
salsa marinara sulla che schifo chef dei
miei stivali
chissà come la cucina te la pasta sarei
veramente curioso di assaggiarla forse
no mannaia penso avesse finito
[Musica]
ragazzo provando a far emersi da 1 ora
aiuto
[Musica]
paga fosse stato per me veramente non
avrei mai risparmiato sul papa ed avrei
fatto fuori subito
arca vacca
[Musica]
ora da quando quando quando dovrebbe
funzionare questa roba perché non sta
funzionando
[Musica]
ahia
raga più mercy di così è impossibile
[Musica]
l'attacco speciale orca vacca
ma cos'è stupido cane ma dai ma poverino
si stava preparando a un attacco
sfruttato mi ha fatto fuori anche così 6
persistente ma non funziona su di me io
odio i persistenti e tu pensi e se e se
pensi di essere un persistente allora è
sbagliato gramma tipicamente sbagliato
perché la corretta forma sarebbe non
persistentemente quanto papyrus che il
persistente nettissimo spero che ti sia
piaciuta questa lezione molto
wow oh mercy significa più clemenza che
più che pietà quindi pt voli e pietà
dove deve durare ancora ragazzi semi per
caso mi compare un'altra volta non so se
farlo fuori o no
conta raccontando che mancano 15 minuti
di live vorrei finire di fare papyrus
quindi adesso mi fa passare lo devo
no ho sbagliato mi aveva chiesto di
combatterlo poteva dirmi di no adesso
poi fai fight
[Musica]
ammazzalo dai doveva ammazzare quindi
non so che fare la continua combattermi
non posso risparmiarlo
[Musica]
paga non so veramente cosa dirvi
possiamo continuare così a sei così sei
anni cosa devo fà
[Musica]
ora che ho fatto mercy un milione di
volte usato fare più i cugini c'è
veramente hanno fatto un miliardo di
volte si mercy avete ragione più
clemenza che pietà c'era che veramente
[Musica]
a
raga non lo uccido perché tutti mi avete
detto di non ucciderlo perché non ho
letto spoiler però cose brutte succedono
dopo solo amazzone quindi non voglio
porco demonio porco morto schifoso
strascicato per terra e figurati tua
madre morta
[Musica]
[ __ ] i quali quelli piccoli non
riesco a schivarli mai perché sono
troppo piccoli porca vacca raga
difficile
[Musica]
ah ok ho mangiato una palla di neve che
mi ha recuperato tutta la vita no le
pensioni neve non era quello che dovevo
portare lontano le protezioni neve porca
vacca
no non avrei voluto mangiarlo che pirla
[Musica]
ahia
sta preparando l'attacco speciale e bene
[Musica]
e vabbè ci siamo
ma
il cane è passato il cane va be cool di
luce
cos'è
[Musica]
vabbè a chi è male ma fatto basta da eco
poca vita che sarei in schiva bile va
bene
non puoi sconfiggerli vabbè comunque per
questo papa ipa papyrus ti garantisco la
pietà si fa lo spero perché spare
pensiero aver pietà
quindi è la tua chance di accettare il
mio la mia clemenza ok papa così styling
in più sei anni
io l'avrei massacrato subito hanno
risparmiato di pon venti minuti di video
però è veramente fatto fuori online sarà
[Musica]
tisa point deluso da me non farò mai
parte delle guardie reali e il mio
tavolo capita
cosa dovrei dire diventiamo amici vuota
loser noi diventiamo davvero da sì però
tranquillo vuoi essere amico con me beh
quindi immagino immagino che posso fare
un'eccezione per di ballo ma sono solo
togliere l'immagine eccezione noi
abbiamo mai avuto una sua prima
appuntamento che già ci sono stati in
grado di raggiunti colpire la friends on
palco se voleva dire
amico tipo del genere non ho mai provato
a fare amicizia l'unica cosa che ho
provato a dare alla gente pessimi enigmi
e combatterli mi ha insegnato tanto
umano enti dalle indicazioni per il di
sopra
continua davanti finché non raggiunge la
fine della caverna poi gerrei la
capitale attraverso la barriera tutti ci
possono passare ma nessuno può uscire
eccetto qualcuno con una potentissima
ali ma come te ed è per questo che non è
vuole che vuole acquisire un umano puoi
aprire la barriera con il potere
dell'anima così che noi nostri possiamo
tornare in superficie e ho dimenticato
di dirti che per aggiungere l'uscita
devi passare attraverso il castello del
re il re di tutti i mostri e lui è the
woods non ho idea di cosa voglia dire
tutti quanti amano quel ragazzo
[Musica]
va bene non ho capito vabbè comunque
abbassa e abbiamo parlato troppo
andrò a casa e sarò un buon amico
sentiti libero di venire e quindi vado
avanti
posso andare avanti c'è dell'acqua c'è
altra acqua c'è un sacco di acqua suns
amico mio
quattro forze poi ragazzi che dite
facciamo una pagina c'è poi cena finiamo
perché sfondo ore e mezza continuano
così mezzanotte
devo fare di tre ore l'ho fatta di due
ore e mezza di mezzanotte non andrei che
dite
va bene allora fatemi uscire qua
fatemici anzi era carina la musica di
sottofondo
per chi se ne frega niente carino mi
piace molto mi piace molto mi piace
molto considerazioni se volete giusto
prima di concludere questo facciamo due
ore e mezzo di live piena
allora mi piace molto è strano
facciamo finta che non abbia giocato a
del tar un e perché del tar un uguale
quindi la tipologia di gioco l'asso
perché ho giocato dal pre molto figo
molto molto figo
mi piace la musica di sottofondo è
bellissima e poi il genere io non gioco
ai giochi umoristici non mi fanno tanto
ridere c'è per farmi ridere ci vuole
veramente tanto
quindi io è raro che io rida invece mi
fa ridere il figo ci sono cose carine
non è scontato sembra che il creatore
abbia ripreso dentro di sé
un talento incredibile che ha poi
esternato nella creazione di under the
c'è nel senso ha fare questa cosa da
tanto l'ha fatta e ha spaccato tutto
molto figo molto molto bello molto molto
bello sei contento di aver ucciso
papyrus no preferivo ammazzarlo facevo
20 minuti in meno
se uno scherzo certo sono contento però
a volte penso che risparmiare la gente
ti faccia perdere un sacco di tempo cioè
nel senso se io avessi spacca all'inizio
ho letto tipo roba tipo ma veramente
perso contro vyrus no è solo che dovevo
risparmiarlo cioè se avessi fatto fight
paziente l'avrei battuto subito però va
beh molto figo molto molto molto figo mi
è piaciuto tanto è piaciuto cioè quelli
che non lo conoscono ovviamente farà un
film saranno fisso undertake dai
veramente molto figo molto figo sono
contento
ci sarà la possibilità di fare la
genocide ma credo che sia una modalità
che si attiva quando fai fuori tutti ma
boh io credo di sta facendo la neutrale
doce siano tre a questo punto pacifiste
neutrale genocide io sto facendo neutra
che ogni tanto risparmio di tanto ogni
tanto uccido poi un po film ha
annunciato che figata
che figata mi piace è carino si ci sta
di allora non era difficile papa i posti
dipende che cosa vuoi fare perché se lo
vuoi uccidere secondo anche tauri al
secondo me era più facile da uccidere
che da risparmiare
che palle
cioè nel senso è una rottura dopo un po
cioè secondo è più fa e secondo me è più
facile uccidere però se vuoi non lo fai
vediamo poi nei prossimi post
pensi che ha ucciso toria sia stata una
cosa ma non a fare no per come mi ha
risposto dopo però ne menava poi l'hanno
messa all'inizio c'è inizia non capisci
neanche troppo bene il concetto di
pacifisti grazie cree storie sori non
tavolino mi dicono piutau rischi e
taurine quella di leo lo hobbit tauri l
chi era tavoli al quale lo hobbit
tauriel è una gnocca paurosa storie sono
scusate unico lavatorio storie o che
bella storia di soldi
come mai così pochi spettatori e
mezzanotte e non faccio fornetto unisce
le due cose
so che non c'entra niente ma mi ha
convinto a guardare io che episodio 6
l'ho finito
guardatelo e molto bello storia non ti
avrebbe comunque ucciso alla fine è mai
io che ne so io non ne ho idea
ti consiglio di andare all'appuntamento
di papà josè va bene ci andrò
molto bello comunque protagonista è lo
stesso di del tar una o sbaglio farlo
continui sotto forma di lei certo la
prossima live continuerò ad arte che
sarà giovedì ieri sera andartene
molto fi comunque non mi è piaciuto
molto veramente c'è poche volte mi piace
una roba tanto questa volta è proprio
bello
[Musica]
devo cambiare con quell'aria delle live
perché di base vorrei fare 21 e 30
mezzanotte più che più che 21 al 23 30
perché alle volte finiscono già un po
tardi
ragazzi io concludo qua ci vediamo
giovedì sera con live di telefono per
sempre under the spero vi sia piaciuta
dai abbiamo è molto molto figo
vediamo come continua bella per papyrus
bella per tutti
ci vediamo la prossima live io vi mando
un bacio
grazie per essere stati con noi state
sintonizzati e noi ci vediamo domani con
un prossimo video e giovedì con la
prossima live da giovedì farò al live
alle 21 e 30
ok continuo under the proprio come oggi
show amici
sion eckstein dove telecomando se questi
scheletri se la velocità mettete mi
piace iscrivetevi noi ci vediamo come
sempre ad un ex video beh ragazzi